bonjour et bienvenue dans notre
laboratoire de cookies artisanal des
Alluets-le-Roi nous allons vous proposer
une visite afin de voir comment se
prépare une pâte à cookies
nous avons ici Alexandre aujourd'hui en
production par exemple en train de faire
le pâtes au caramel beurre salé dans un
robot ici présent qui nous permet de
préparer en une seule fois
approximativement mille cookies vous
avez sa table de travail son frigo dans
lequel il stock c'est eux son beurre et
vous avez actuellement donc la dresseuse
qui est en route qui nous permet de
peser précisément des petits pâtons au
poids requêté avant de passer au
dressage des plaques de cuisson
vous avez donc à ce titre ni Nelly ici
présente qui est en train de dresser des
brookies donc un dérivé de notre pâte à
cookies un format 120 g carré très
généreux et qui propose donc de préparer
ces grilles sur une échelle à
destination du four ici présent qui nous
permet de cuire 300 cookies toutes les
10 15 minutes
[Musique]
il est important effectivement de
vérifier la cuisson en fin de process ça
peut se jouer à une ou deux minutes près
et effectivement pour vraiment arriver à
la texture qu'on souhaite proposer à nos
clients croustillant sur le dessus
fondant à l'intérieur on se doit d'avoir
une cuisson très précise et on a beau
avoir un Super Four très très fiable en
température et vraiment du top du top il
faut quand même être alerte sur les
dernières instants de cuisson pour être
certain d'être vraiment sur le produit
qu'on souhaite proposer à tous
démarrage en 2015 c'est deux amis
d'enfance donc pierre moi-même et Tim
l'envie de créer quelque chose de bon au
départ d'artisanat tous notre
développement est basé énormément sur
les produits de qualité le circuit court
donc c'est au départ une idée de se dire
voilà faire quelque chose de bon de
frais et d'innovant aussi qu'on voit pas
partout vers chez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
va chercher les œufs
[Musique]
comment vas-tu
360 est prête on a nos 360 œufs du jour
c'est parfait on va pouvoir transformer
tout ça en cookies exactement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on produit entre 2000
environ 2000 cookies par jour clairement
entre 1500 et 2000 ça va ça va rien un
petit peu donc on est sur une base de
entre 40 et 50 000 cookies par mois
l'objectif 2023 c'est de passer à 60 000
cookies par mois et 2024 de doubler donc
80000 cookies par mois on a plein de
petites pépites dans nos boutiques comme
du thé matcha du yuzu meringue cranberry
chocolat blanc en ce moment voilà on
essaie de de diversifier au maximum et
de s'adresser au plus de personnes à
tous les gourmands en tout cas
[Musique]